It's not that the election was rigged per se by
the States or the vote counters or mail in ballots.
It's that it was essentially rigged by CNN, Los Angeles, times,
New York times, most all legacy and mainstream media,
and then big tech and, you know,
all the Googles and the Twitter and all that, all that.
It was rigged by them essentially. And if you really think about it,
it's not much hyperbole.
All right. Let's talk about the election a little bit.
I'm just giving you like the whole landscape of all the craziness of the world,
the election, where he at at this point,
apparently Joe Biden is the president elect.
I don't think you voted for Joe Biden. Did you, did,
did you officially announce who you voted for? I know where,
where you're at politically, but did you actually say it?
No, but, uh, I would definitely vote for Trump over, over by, um,
the, the, the interesting take on it, which isn't,
you know, insanely impressive in terms of the math, but, uh,
sort of what Ben Shapiro is always been talking about for the last several
weeks,
which is it's not that the election was rigged
per se by the States or the vote counters or
mail in ballots. It's that it was essentially rigged by CNN,
Los Angeles, times, New York times,
most all legacy and mainstream media, and then big tech,
you know, all the Googles and the Twitter and all that, all that.
It was rigged by them essentially. And if you really think about it,
it's not much hyperbole. I mean,
if you think about just the Hunter Biden story,
as an example, and you go, okay,
and forget it's Hunter Biden and forget what the allegations are and forget
anything. Let's just be generic. There's a story, it's a credible story.
And it would hurt one candidate.
And I don't know if that means three points or seven points,
or I don't know what it would translate into,
but it would definitely be damaging to one of the candidates. So in our,
in our hypothetical world,
there's a candidate and B candidate and B candidate would definitely be
hurt by a story that comes out several days before
the big election.
And then all the legacy news organizations.
And then, and then Silicon Valley,
they all conspire to crush a story and are saying things like
Russian disinformation or there's no proof whatsoever.
So that story never comes out. Well,
I would argue that that is tampering with the election.
It's certainly affecting the election. I mean,
guess if you say what's the definition of tampering with an election,
I guess the definition would be affecting the election one way or the
other for this candidate or that candidate.
So there are all onboard to do this. They always do this thing.
It's funny when the smartest people in the world, the Silicon Valley guys go,
Oh yeah, we didn't know what was going on with that thing. We made a mistake.
We're going to get better processes. We should have looked at that before.
Right. You didn't know. Huh. And, and by the way,
it's pretty simple. Uh, they found a laptop, had a bunch of information on it.
Might you have some follow-up questions or we just announced that's Russian
disinformation. So you had a whole group of people.
And when I say a group, I mean, most 90% of the media,
essentially running interference for one of the candidates and,
and all the way through just, you know, the COVID vaccines,
never going to come out before the end of the year, et cetera.
And every single story, uh, yeah, that's going to translate into a few points.
And that is, that is the tampering.
I think there's anything left at this point in terms of mainstream media.
Like I think if,
if my one takeaway probably of the year beyond
lockdowns and the way we give up freedoms and all that,
but like my one sort of tangible takeaway is that there is simply nothing left
in mainstream media.
That doesn't mean that a hundred percent of reporters are all artists,
but I think the way they treated the Hunter by it in story,
then the way we were immediately told not to look at anything related to
election fraud. And if we did, we're,
we're basically Alex Jones and everything else, like to me,
there's nothing left, you know, Washington post New York times CNN,
like it's just done. Am I, am I over the top?
Well, there's something left, but the question is,
is what did they do to their brand? So if you think about,
think about what the Oscars means in 2021,
versus the Oscars from our childhood, it was first off,
it was appointment viewing, get the whole family,
see who the best picture of the year who got the,
and the best picture of the year got that was the best picture of the year.
You know, I mean,
we didn't argue about it and we didn't think there was any politics involved and
it just was, you know, and by the way, you know,
when you look at the ratings for the shows, you realize it,
ain't what it used to be by, by long shot. And,
and I'll give you a couple examples. So think about the Oscars.
Think about the Amies think,
think about how I did a little experiment around here.
I've young people work for me. I said, uh,
if you heard a story out of CNN five years ago, what would you have thought?
And they went, I would believed it. And I'd say, what do you think now?
And they go, eh, I'd have to go look into it. So CNN,
New York times, all, all the entities you mentioned, but also Oscars,
Amie, uh, maybe the NBA, uh, rotten tomatoes,
you know, you see a hillbilly Elegy, Oh, it's 24% with the critics,
but 88 with the people, Oh, what a shocker, you know,
no safe spaces is I dunno,
44% with the critics and 90% with the people. So,
so now we no longer have to go to,
we don't have to find out what the critics have to say on, uh, rotten tomatoes,
because it's skewed. Everything is skewed and whoever wins,
the Oscar is going to be, you know, Oh, he's the,
he's the black gay teen is struggling with his sexuality. Like, okay, I get it.
And, and, and by the way, when you do that,
you are shaking hands with the devil. You really are in terms of your brand,
the Oscars should have never let all this super woke in.
Because once you announce,
we now need 50% people of color nominated for the best
actor. It's over, we stop, we stop. We go, well,
were they the best actors or is they just meeting a quota?
So they're shooting themselves in the foot.
But the best part of it is they decided to put all these quotas in about,
you know, skin, color, and sexuality. And you know,
if you're a midget or you have a lazy eye or whatever, except they said,
we're not going to do it for three years.
It's so important to solve racism and sexism,
but we still have some stuff in the can.
So we got to get that racist crap out of the way. And we'll do it,
do it in three years. You mentioned no safe spaces.
So I'm sure most of my audience has seen it already. But when,
when you think back to the project,
cause you guys probably you and Dennis and the team probably started working on
this thing, what like four years ago, maybe something like that.
W when you think back to the project, I mean, basically everything.
And I'm not just saying it cause, cause we both happen to be in it.
But everything that no safe spaces is about,
which in essence is that all of this woke craziness from the college campus is
going to leak into re into real society. It's what everyone sees now.
And we were all told we were racists and bigots and the rest of it.
If we're talking about it, are you, are you kind of,
are you like impressed that we kind of called it?
Or are you depressed that we kind of called it or just is what it is?
Cause we called it, we all called it. Now everyone knows that that is the,
the stuff that is happening everywhere right now.
Well, first off, how could it not like, what if,
what if your kid leaves for college?
And then every one of their professors is a vegan and then they're teaching
classes on meat is murder. Don't tell your chef husband.
Cause he makes a delectable Wagyu. I think we have.
Did I hear correctly on your podcast?
I think the day or a day or two after you came over here for dinner, I,
you said it was the best steak you ever had.
It was man. So,
so kudos to you for a living with that.
I was doing this. Oh. You're.
Right.
Yeah, no, I had a cup. I had a couple of scotches at that point.
Sorry, Dave, you get all credit to Dave Rubin for doing the, doing the steak,
but um, the hell we're talking about, and I forgot about it.
That you send,
if you send your kids to these schools and they're being taught by them.
Oh yeah. Okay. So everyone's a vegan and meat is murder. Uh,
how long before your kids starts coming home for Thanksgiving and saying, no,
thanks to the Turkey because meat is murder.
And then when those kids in their vegan environment get pushed
out into main street and Madison Avenue and start showing up at
corporations,
how long before they start judging people for eating a ham sandwich and how
could it go any other way? Of course, it's going to go that way. I mean,
you get,
you go to this place where a bunch of ideology is taught to you and then
the construct, or,
or at least college is basically there to,
I mean, if you think about what, what is the, what,
what is the mission statement for college? Well,
you go to this place for four years, we teach you a bunch of stuff.
And then you take that with you into society. Right? Well,
we just thought it was going to be a bunch of engineering and calculus and you
know, art history.
We didn't know what was going to be an indoctrination to a bunch of ideas,
but it is.
And I would argue those ideas are more powerful than engineering are because you
can't just walk into your new job at Kinko's and start talking to everyone about
structural engineering or shear loads or tension anchors or something.
They're not going to, it's not going to take,
but if you start talking to everyone about your ideology,
then it's going to spread. And that's exactly where we're living.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.